So my only concern is generating the leads right now.
Well, so that's something that you can't really control.
So what I would do is do everything that you can
to make sure that they're coming in.
But don't, like a lot of you guys,
I think the leads aren't coming in.
You go and tweak something on Google,
like, oh, negative keywords, change the keywords,
change the budget.
I think every time you do that,
there's like this process, this period of time
that it has to like recalibrate.
Just leave the leads alone.
If you did it right the first time, just leave them alone.
There's nothing else you can do.
And then what I would do is go do what Ashley did,
or not Ashley, it was Tara.
She was right there and she needed like one more lead.
She literally went on Facebook and found somebody
in that area on like a marketplace
that needed a recommendation,
direct messaged them and got an extra lead.
It was the very lead that she used to close the deal.
Nice.
That was very neat.
Like what city is this in?
Richmond.
So go to Richmond, buy, sell, trade, or whatever the group.
Richmond, there's like, you know,
these Facebook groups go in there
and just do smart searches like recommendation
or deck builder.
And there's going to be some posts
and nine times out of 10, you're going to find some,
it's like, hey, who knows a good deck builder,
message them, boom.
It didn't, you didn't come from Google,
but it's a lead is a lead is a lead is a lead.
And that's like a little hustle you got to do,
but that might be just what you need
to get it over the edge.